and the vma goes too
[Applause]
[Music]
my brand new album comes out october
21st
are you ready for it swifties an all new
taylor album is coming
i'm so excited and so are we tay made
the big announcement at the 2022 vmas
after winning video of the year
i had sort of
made up my mind that if you were going
to be this generous
and give us this
i thought it might be a fun moment to
tell you that my brand new album comes
out october 21st
and i will tell you more at midnight
and that she did revealing her 10th
album is actually titled midnight's and
will feature 13 tracks the albums
inspired by sleepless nights scattered
throughout taylor's life like how lucky
am i
we think swifties are the lucky ones
[Music]
the conspiracy theories started as soon
as taylor posted this tick tock sporting
a sparkly look that reminded fans of her
look what you made me do music video
i
don't
like your perfect crime how
you laugh when you lie
and remember that sparkly bathtub moment
was seemingly inspired by taylor's dress
at the 2009 vmas you know where this
happened
yo taylor
i'm really happy for you i'm let you
finish but beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time all that had the
internet detectives speculating that
taylor would be announcing her
re-recording of reputation taylor's
version at the vmas
[Music]
and that may still come but first we're
getting midnight my brand new album
comes out october 21st
and that release date could just be
another reputation easter egg because
it's kim kardashian's birthday and we
all know kim yay inspired a lot of
reputation i will tell you more at
midnight
the big announcement capped off a big
night for tay she went home with three
awards making history with her third
video of the year win for all too well
10-minute version taylor's version
[Music]
i'm so
honored to have been recognized
alongside
such amazing artists and directors in
this category and i just want to say i'm
so heartened by the fact
that
for the first time in vma history
four
of the directors nominated in the video
of the year category
are women
then taylor thanked her biggest
supporters her fans you guys i'm just so
proud of what we made and i i know with
ever every second
of this moment that
we wouldn't have been able to make this
short film
if it weren't for you the fans
because
i wouldn't be able to
re-record my albums if it weren't for
you
the fans are the people who turned it
into something very empowering where
when they they were just saying to me
over and over again we want to listen to
your versions if you redo it that's what
we'll listen to so if they hadn't if
they hadn't done that i don't think i'd
be having this amazing
exciting experience of being here and
you're here and there's a short film of
one of my favorite songs i've ever
written and so that's all the fans doing
and so this is really i just wanted to
think about what could i do over the
course of one week that would make them
as happy
or try to make them as happy as they've
made me
[Music]
you